this video is brought to you by
Skillshare whatsup wisecrack jared again
now you would think that after almost 20
years of some of the most intense fan
hatred ever thumbs way down you didn't
like you know I think I deserve a public
apology from George Lucas there'd be
nothing new to say about the worst star
war the Phantom Menace and yet here we
are after the release of Return of the
Jedi in 1983 millions of fans begged
George Lucas to create a new Star Wars
film studio executives begged him toy
makers begged him and after constantly
saying no finally in 1999 everyone got
their wish George Lucas released The
Phantom Menace problem solved except not
really upon release
Star Wars fans rose up in fury and
demanded the head of George Lucas on a
Tuscan spike they rallied together in
AOL chat rooms and Yahoo message boards
and for the first time in the short
history of the Internet fans from across
the world banded together in the
righteous cause of tearing George Lucas
a new one for the unforgivable sin that
was making this movie and hey look they
had a point The Phantom Menace for lack
of better word sucks hundreds of
articles essays and videos have been
written about how it sucks
shout out mr. plinkus so you might like
the characters you know you're stupid
and why it sucks so much so that it has
become a given that there's absolutely
nothing redeemable about this movie but
what if that's not entirely true relax
I'm not going to argue that
midi-chlorians were a great idea it is
possible he was conceived instead I want
to talk about what the Phantom Menace
gets almost right because conceptually
there are some very promising themes at
play here namely Nazis it's no secret
that the original trilogy largely wanted
you to conflate the Empire with the
Third Reich from the costumes to the use
of colour and of course naming the
soldiers stormtroopers but how did the
galaxy get to be this way like Nazi
Germany which descended into
totalitarianism through democratic means
George Lucas aspired to portray
something immensely important with the
prequels how a peaceful Republic can
democratically descend into full-blown
Nazism so what went wrong
well let's find out welcome to this
wisecrack edition on Star Wars Episode
one The Phantom Menace what went wrong
and can you spoil a movie with no plot
oh and if you want to hear us nerd out
about the Disney Star Wars backlash
check out our special episode on our
movie podcast show me the meaning you
will smash that link in the description
for everyone who hasn't seen this in
over a decade here's a brief recap an
organization called the Trade Federation
is protesting trade taxes by blockading
trade with the planet in the booth but I
guess it doesn't have to make sense
because really they're doing it all for
their boy Darth Sidious aka Senator
Palpatine the Republic sends a certain
qui-gon jinn and his apprentice obi-wan
Kenobi to negotiate but the Trade
Federation tries to kill them they flee
to the surface of Naboo which is now
being invaded by the Trade Federation
encounter the worst character ever
conceived in cinematic history save the
queen and try to zoom off to the
Galactic Senate where they can explain
what a bunch of jerks the Trade
Federation is but they get shot up and
have to find supplies on Tatooine where
they meet a nice slave boy with
incredible force blood there's some like
gambling they liberate the boy leave his
mother to rot and head to the Senate to
plead their case there's a battle
qui-gon dies obi-wan murders Darth Maul
and Palpatine is now the head honcho of
the Galactic Senate also Jar Jar is a
general hmm the original trilogy won't
wonderfully enjoyable are not complex
works of emotional art and they're not
intended to be there updates of the
Flash Gordon and Buck Rogers serials
from Lucas's childhood the heroes were
good men who often wore white and the
villains were evil men who often wore
black just like Luke Skywalker and Darth
Vader there's no ambiguity here and
that's okay the Phantom Menace on the
other hand is quite ambiguous qui-gon
lies and cheats his way through most of
the story he as per the light side of
the force
quietly meditates before his final
confrontation against Darth Maul and
gets wrecked
obi-wan fills with rage and emotion
associated with the dark side and only
then can he effectively avenge his
master
not quite the black-and-white morality
of the first three films but most
notable is our benevolent heroine Queen
Amidala she spends the Phantom Menace
trying to save her people but for all
her noble intentions she mostly gets
manipulated by Senator Palpatine and
even proves integral in getting him
elected Supreme Chancellor when good
leads to victory for evil we've entered
the realm of the morally ambiguous in
his essay heart and moral education
philosopher Christopher Hamilton
expounds on the richness of such moral
ambiguity in so much as they forces to
confront our own moral beliefs it's a
sign of great art so did the Phantom
Menace give us that gut punch that comes
with us reevaluating our own moral
beliefs of course it did right right
okay just kidding I felt nothing all 20
times I've seen this movie ambiguity is
a great idea when dealing with complex
issues like political systems Trade
Federation planetary autonomy solving
humanitarian crises so why didn't it
work because the characters have no
agency father Chuck when dick who has
written extensively on the subject
defines agency and fiction as a
demonstration of the characters ability
to make decisions and affect the story
they have motivations of their own they
are active more than they are reactive
they push the plot more than the plot
pushes on them in contrast he writes
that characters without agency tend to
be like little paper boats bobbing down
a river of your own making
they cannot steer they cannot change the
course of the river the river is an
external force that carries them along
meaning the plastics it's hand up the
characters cavernous bottom hole and
makes the character do things and say
things in service to the plot in the
Phantom Menace it's almost like Lucas
took this rule of bad writing and ran
with it qui-gon and Anakin and Padme and
obi-wan and God help me Jar Jar Binks
are nothing but little paper boats they
have no internal conflict no external
life
no personal obsession outside of what
the film dictates and that River pushing
them along well as
we later learn it's the dark side the
dark side clouds everything impossible
to see and the biggest casualty besides
the time you and I just wasted being
bored is the political message itself
the best example of this is the story of
Queen Amidala Padme along with many of
the other characters are mere pawns of
Palpatine that's not necessarily a bad
thing but as we'll see Palpatine's
manipulations quickly turn into how to
cover a bad writing 101 here's what we
know about Padme she's a queen who
doesn't want to submit to some invader
because well that's what Queens do she
also likes democracy because hey she's
not evil
so in Star Wars how does a queen who
likes democracy lead to the eventual
downfall of said democracy she gets
manipulated Palpatine creates a crisis
on Naboo which mirrors the prototypical
false flag attack of the Reichstag fire
and she has to plead to the Senate to
intervene but Palpatine since he's smart
knows their feckless bureaucrats and
will do nothing he plants the seed in
Amidala's mind i must be frank oh man
just a that his little chance the Senate
will act on the invasion she sees his
warning come true this is will you defer
your motion to allow a commission to
explore the validity of your accusations
and calls for the Supreme Chancellor to
be ousted I move no confidence in
Chancellor valorum's leadership so that
a real statesman can take charge and cut
through the bureaucratic red tape that
real statesmen just happens to be our
ambitious senator and future Emperor
sheev Palpatine aka Darth Sidious here's
where our paper boats become a problem
characters without agency are well
boring but in this case of trying to get
into the complexity of not only how
democracies fail but how well-meaning
people are implicated paper-boat
characters robbed us of our ability to
reflect on what's actually happening
beat for beat it makes sense
Palpatine warns her of something she
sees his warning come true so she falls
for the deception it even sounds good
but maybe because lucas was too busy
cramming in 8000
dumb lines for this guy it falls flat
each beat could have confronted our
character with a choice
they might deliberate over struggle with
or at least talk about this choice
she might argue with Palpatine she might
confide in a friend she might reach out
to an outside government for help she
might deny Palpatine's bargain at all
costs until the toll on her citizenry
gets too high but in the Phantom Menace
things just kind of happen because
everyone is a pawn
not a person with agency and that
destroys our ability as the audience to
reflect on these issues when we identify
with the characters we identify with
their dilemma asking ourselves what
would I do when in the Dark Knight The
Joker rigs two boats with explosives to
give each one the power to obliterate
the other before they get obliterated
themselves I blow you all up we bite our
nails as we debate the merits of killing
someone else to save our own skin
there's no such tension in the Phantom
Menace because Padme is just Palpatine's
puppet and what's the deal with the
other senators what are their
motivations who knows we're just told
when and how they side with Palpatine
and to make matters worse at no point as
Padme regret the decision that would
eventually destroy democracy in the
Phantom Menace or in the later movies if
her initial decision to remove the
Supreme Chancellor from power gives us
no room to empathize and think at least
we can empathize and think about her
regret but no for a woman who later says
this
and their surplus you might at least
expect her to sob quietly in some corner
because she literally made this happen
by contrast consider Jaime Lannister
from Game of Thrones he was a loyal
guard to the Mad King except when the
Mad King tried to incinerate all of his
citizens
Jaime broke his sacred oath and murdered
the person he swore to protect and the
King turned to flee I drove my sword in
his back
Jaime is haunted by this decision as
he's derisively called Kinsler for the
rest of his life and while he probably
made the right choice he's also acutely
aware that he is more or less
responsible for the current show in
Westeros he takes responsibility for the
choices he made and that allows us to
identify with him or we can even look at
rogue one where a good character's
involvement in the creation of the Death
Star is put front and center not only
does this lack of agency Rob meaning
from the how democracy dies theme in The
Phantom Menace but it also makes all of
Lucas's topical and timely takes on news
of the decade more or less meaningless
The Phantom Menace came out in the late
90s just years after governments in
Bosnia and Rwanda had committed genocide
so when the queen of Naboo is pleading
to an international I mean
interplanetary government body to
intervene in the slaughter of her people
George Lucas's inspiration was pretty
obvious on a narrative level do we care
not really
vague shoutouts the current events don't
a good political allegory make you need
choices instead we understand it as just
another step in Palpatine's greater
machinations when the Senate fails to do
anything we don't understand their
motivations for doing so or their
personal failings aside from a line or
two from Palpatine describing them as
ineffectual and then there's the Trade
Federation talk of taxes and trade in
the opening crawl was likely meant to
invoke contemporary debates about
globalization and free trade right on
the heels of NAFTA which was passed in
1994 and anti-globalization protests so
what does the Trade Federation want why
did the Senate pass taxes on trade who
the [ __ ] knows it's also worth noting
that aside from the political themes
characters getting pushed along the
narrative stream with no choice is
everywhere
in the case of Jar Jar he literally
succeeds via incompetence in the Battle
of Naboo his fumbling and carelessness
accidentally release whatever these are
which destroy a bunch of enemy droids I
think this must be what business people
mean by failing up and then there's
Anakin who pushes a bunch of wrong
buttons which ferry him to the droid
ship where he can press a few more
buttons to save the day so what if this
is the real curse of the Phantom Menace
because it could have been a powerful
movie more importantly it could have
been a powerful children's movie and
joined the likes of Harry Potter as kid
fictions covering horrific political
history but it's not not even close just
mark it down as another example of
grandiose ambitions ending in a
faceplant indeed there are few things
more painful than missing the mark on
projects you pour your life and soul
into I would know
so before you dive headfirst into your
next endeavor you're gonna want to make
sure you're equipped with all the skills
you need to make it a success with
Skillshare the online learning community
you can take over 20,000 classes and
design business technology and more how
to be a Jedi Master not included premium
memberships give you unlimited access to
high-quality classes on must know topics
so you can improve your skills unlock
new opportunities and do the work that
you love if you're looking to start your
own business like we did with wisecrack
I highly recommend skill shares classes
on entrepreneurship including art of the
start turning ideas into high-growth
businesses brand strategy building a
business that lasts and entrepreneurship
online business planning 101 join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for wisecrack viewers get two
months of Skillshare premium for free by
heading over to sk l sh slash wisecrack
xi or clicking the link in the
description below may the force be with
you and as always peace